let's go through all three cases
let's go through all three cases okay
number one
they announce trump wins next tuesday
night they announce because it's a
landslide
right he does a you know mondale reagan
type of deal and
crushes biden let's just say he wins
what happens if biden wins
what happens if nobody wins
and they delayed for one week what
happens okay
so give me each of those situation what
happens with riots protesting civil war
potential for you know ramifications
or is it going to become people will get
over it after week what's going to
happen in any of those situations take
place
uh i think if trump wins the exact same
thing that happened last time is going
to happen
there's going to be you know not my
president people marching in the streets
worse or about the same probably worse
probably worse probably
unpack that what does that mean what's
that what does that mean how do what
does worse mean
worse means more violence than last time
oh more violence well
the people that are that are committing
violence have been enabled
by the the violence takes place in the
big cities the big cities are run by
democrats the democrats have basically
told their police force stand down
let them do what they want let them spit
in your face let them burn your police
cars let them throw molotov cocktails
into windows where babies could be
sleeping
and don't do anything about it i'm
certainly in chicago that's that's just
unbelievable we have a prosecutor who
just will not prosecute this i mean you
know they'll prosecute you if you stole
a pack of gum from a 7-eleven
you'd be in jail for 10 years but these
people can do whatever they want and so
they're completely emboldened and you
know
they've gone so far as to say well
looting is reparations and that you know
they've just made it about race and
you know when race is not even
necessarily an issue even this george
floyd thing there's not
looting is reparation you didn't hear
that in chicago
i don't know if it was in chicago it was
definitely some looters i think it was
in chicago actually okay
they were talking about losing so yours
is gonna be worse i think it's gonna be
worse and you know
this is this is their fight and you got
a lot of people out of work they've got
time they go out in the street obviously
some of them are actually hired
they're professional protesters a friend
of mine was he was on vacation one time
he was telling me he was that he was
sitting at a pool he was talking to some
woman
and what do you do she says i'm a
professional you know
rabble rouser protester you know and how
much you make when she was making good
money
there's people actually on the payroll
to go and just you know they fly them
into these
professional rebel browsers well you
know protester rioter whatever you want
to call it and you know to say that
this stuff is peaceful as as the stuff
is burning in the background
mostly peaceful protests whatever it is
what it is
the problem is there that some somebody
needs to bring law and order back
onto our streets it isn't going to be
the democratic mayors they're not going
to do it so i don't know how that how
order
comes i think there's going to be a lot
of violence what if biden wins uh
maybe the same because they've been
emboldened now they're thinking that
well now
why are their same though well now
they're they're going to be so
um i'm trying to describe i i'm not
jubilee
celebration like the lakers winning
flipping car yeah
okay like that yeah yeah okay okay so so
biden wins not as bad as trump winning
and it's going to be a little bit more
uh calmer but what if neither wins and
they go into
record battle yeah 32 days al gore
situations there's people on both sides
probably marching and saying hey you
know
you know we want our guy to win they're
going to do whatever they can
which one's going to cause the biggest
havoc trump winning biden winning or
undecided tough to say
it's really tough okay what do you say
adam so
um one thing that like we talked about
this at dinner last night
this is a you know very emotional
situation a lot not a lot of logic going
on especially right now
sure some people are thinking with their
heads cooler heads prevail
is it a very emotional situation i want
my candidate i want my candidate i don't
care
but yeah i hate the other side i hate
the other side screw this screw that
a lot of emotions running very high for
sure well can we agree on that
absolutely clearly uh i happen to think
that
there will be no clear winner on
election night
i think the at least according to the
polls and i know that people out there
can't believe the polls in no way can we
believe the polls i happen to be one of
those people who
finds the polls to be at least somewhat
credible it's definitely not 100
accuracy
but at least some sort of guide what the
guide basically says is this is likely
to be
drawn out for at least a handful of days
potentially a few weeks
i think it is incumbent on the media on
the media
whether you're on the left you're on the
right you want trump you want biden
don't give a [ __ ] to inform your
listeners
guys this is going to take some time let
the
let the system play out let's
all calm the temperatures and i think
that amount of time
at least will it start to inform people
look this is how this process works
i was in tallahassee at florida state
university in 2000
and what happened in tallahassee in 2000
that was gore versus bush it happened
right there we were going to college at
that point i was a junior in college i
remember
news news every single day every single
day every day after a month of it
we're just like all right like can we
get this freaking show on the road can
they pick a winner already
and it kind of took it played out and
played its course obviously bush won the
election
so what's my point you asked what are
the three what are the three options i
think number one if trump wins
people are going to go [ __ ] insane on
the left
[ __ ] insane what do you mean
everything we've been seeing for the
last
worse yes yes i think again
their rationale will be what again high
on emotion
not a lot of logic so if trump
legitimately wins keyword there
legitimately
the country's spoken two years in a row
i mean what else could you say you hate
the guy
he sucks he's an orange animal he's an
[ __ ] cool i get it i get it i get it
but the guy has won yeah two elections
in a row
on the flip side whether you love trump
or you don't love trump
one thing that has been undeniable he
has never had over a 50
approval rating let me say that again he
has never had over a 50
approval rating okay so no president and
i think has won the election twice
back to back without a 50 so if he loses
people have to understand yeah joe biden
might be one of the worst candidates
we've seen in modern american politics
but that's a function of he beat also
someone who is not
very highly approved okay it doesn't
have high approval ratings so
again i don't think biden's going to
blow him out and i definitely don't
think that as the numbers show that
trump is going to blow him out
i think this is going to be something
that's going to take a few weeks and
as much as the media has been holding
what happens
obviously there's going to be some maga
people out there they're going to be
highly highly disappointed i think mega
people will riot
and protest no yes you think you think
that
i think there will be a
i mean a percentage of the people that
will not be
you don't you think they're just gonna
say happy well i guess i guess biden won
the the bigger question is not so much
the mag of people
the bigger question is do you think
trump is gonna say well
i lost 330 to 220 electoral college i
clearly lost
and it's time for me to leave leave
office uh willingly
do you actually think trump will do that
no problem yes
you think trump is just going to leave
office i lost the election
thanks guys i'm going to go back to it's
fair and square he'll he'll leave
straight up
yep you don't think he's going to say it
was mail-in ballots it was fraud you
don't see that at all byron no
really if there was mail in ballots and
there was fraud if there was fraud he
may point it out okay i'm telling you if
he gets blown out
loses 40 out of five he leaves without
any issue
correct i just don't see trump he's not
that kind of guy what do you think
so what if what if it drags out what if
it drags out a week anything happens or
no
i think there's going to be chaos in the
streets which of those three is going to
create the highest level of chaos trump
winning
dragging out or biden winning in my
opinion i think if trump wins
the the people on the left are going to
lose their flipping
mind okay kai you were going to say
something um
the only thing i was going to say was i
think regarding if there's going to be
protests with trump
if he doesn't win i think that kind of
goes back to depends on how he's
reacting if he's egging
a mag a crowd on then obviously they're
going to do as is told almost
meaning instigating yeah if he's
instigating oh this is this this is this
then i can see it being like oh you need
to go
interesting do this or protest that he's
unfiltered but he's not stupid
no no i'm i'm not saying there's no end
game to that if he thinks that just
doing that just going to cause a bunch
of violence
why would he do that how is he going to
win what evidence has been a winning
game
what evidence have we seen we've only
seen evidence of sore losing on the left
we haven't seen it on the right when we
haven't seen him winning on the right
obama won twice did you see any riots
what evidence do we have of trump saying
you know what guys thank you for the
opportunity to be president
it's been an honor to serve as your
president for the last four years
clearly you guys have selected joe biden
to be your president he's won the
election
and that's it for me yeah
probably get a few digs in but yes by
and large that's what's going to happen
you have a higher view of how trump will
respond to this than
than a lot of people i will tell you i
think he's going to be salty
a f i think he's going to say that it's
fraud
i think this is why you hear on the left
we can't just win by two or three points
we need to win by 10 points